there was a lot of improvisation yeah in
the booth is that right Zach Kumail you
guys would improvise a little bit
sometimes in the booth and it would get
a little dirty wouldn't it we're on a
HBO show so you sort of get used to
improvising in that vein we're on an HBO
show where the most famous bit is how
quickly can you jerk we would forget or
at least I would forget it was a kids
movie I remember it was like well why
don't you go home and choke yourself
with the belt while you my guess is
there at least for a publicist backstage
before the lego ninjago movie do you
think it's fantastic and it would get
dark you guys would go to dark places
yeah I mean you know I don't think it
gets darker and choke yourself to death
while you're masturbating it's tough to
top that yeah
you know yeah we would and they were
like the director was so supportive cuz
right after Zach did that they were like
all right let's take a moment that was
really good but there's no way that they
would let that cuz we just Charlie the
director is so great he came up with
this this thing that he was like
hopefully that this do you'll let us do
it and my character I play the mom to
dave Franco and trying to cheer enough
chair mob so I made his favorite dish
was we're dumpling and the whole bit was
just if I could just say we'll just take
a dump on your way to bed we'll just
take one of moms dumps with you you love
mom's dumps come on they're dumb like
and we already take a few dumps at
school I'm not dumps come on you love
mom's dumpster moms don't frighten your
mouths mom
that means we could pass that they said
no way to that so definitely no way to
dumps and no way to yeah so the
standards for the movie are much higher
than what we're doing here now yeah
right when they said that's not gonna
work I was like I'm gonna say it on
Conan
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you